so what I wanted to do today it's it's
sort of a tradition that we have that I
start the state of summit by talking
about our kind of evolving view of data
and also somehow doing a bunch of
adventure demos that I've never done
before so I'll them I'll be doing that
here we'll see what fraction of them
work well this year actually I think we
have a very big story that's been kind
of developing for close to 30 years now
and it's it's kind of made possible in
many ways by a sort of deepening view of
data and it has to do with a Wolfram
language system that we've just started
to bring out this year and that as I say
we've been working towards for a very
very long time both Mathematica and Wolf
malva have been essentially building
blocks of what is now emerging as the as
the as the Wolfram language me just
start off here so oops so kind of the
the goal with the Wolfram language is to
make sort of a new kind of computer
language that is knowledge based typical
computer languages the idea is the
language consists of a small set of
primitives and perhaps people over the
course of time build libraries for
different kinds of things in that
language but the the language is kept
sort of as small and simple as possible
and kind of just wraps around the
fundamental operations of a computer our
goal with the Wolfram language and it's
taken sort of 30 years to build towards
this goal is to do something in a sense
much more ambitious to do something
which really takes advantage of all the
knowledge that we now have and to sort
of have a knowledge-based language in
which as much knowledge and automation
is built into the language as possible
so kind of the the idea is that directly
within the language we have capabilities
for all kinds of different things and
the notion is that we should set it up
so that we as humans sort of specify as
as little as possible to sort of specify
our goals in a simple way as possible
and then
up to the system to figure out
automatically how to achieve those goals
as well as it can and and also in order
to do that we have to build in a lot of
knowledge part of sort of that knowledge
is algorithmic knowledge actual all the
various different kinds of algorithms
and meta algorithms to do all sorts of
different kinds of things and part of it
is is is data and as we built out this
language a crucial element is its
interaction with the cloud and in a
sense the very existence of this
knowledge based language is made
possible by interaction with the cloud
and by the fact that we can store
terabytes of data in the cloud curated
and ready for the language to use well
wolfram alpha has been sort of our
consumer way to present the the
knowledge that we've accumulated and so
let's just let's just start up with an
offer here sort of the idea of autumn
alpha is if it wakes up oh I think I
should sign in I got it I got to support
our pro version the so so the idea is
you you ask it a question it tries to
give you a report of the answer I
suppose a good this was a query that I
when wolf mouthful was first was first
developed this was a query I said would
never work but it turned out there is
data on on the number of goats in France
and all kinds of other good things like
that um I think we can ask into let's do
this oh it's bad sign let's say we ask
it about something which involves
real-time data is sort of an interesting
combination of a feed a real-time feed
of data an actual computation of
celestial mechanics to figure out where
where this particular satellite will be
and if we go and scroll down it'll tell
us some it'll tell us things that it
computes based on where it thinks we
things that are relevant like when will
this rise from the place that thinks my
computer is in right now so we've been
steadily adding
all sorts of different kinds of detailed
data to the system so we can ask it you
know how many oh do speakers are there
in the US and hopefully it will respond
and tell us that or um it'll tough we
can ask it something like come as some
result okay it's about the same number
of people has attended the Woodstock
fair and so on we could ask it time
something like come how many baseball's
fit in a Boeing 747 and that that
requires some some combination of kinds
of knowledge and gives us an answer of
4.8 million there or we could ask it
let's say let's say we could ask it
about tum a let's try asking about
hurricane
which hopefully will didn't spell
correctly but anyway again this this
requires some feed a real-time data and
then combining that in a variety of ways
with actual computation now let me see
if I can get one more thing to work yeah
there we go so let's so but that's for
example here's another there's another
kind of query we can ask it about van
gogh's starry night and it should know
something about that too and it'll have
an image and it'll tell us some all
sorts of things about when it was
painted relative to van Gogh's life I
didn't know was actually so late in his
life okay that's interesting oh we can
the wolf Martha gets used sort of every
day by millions of people lots of
professionals lots of students for some
of the for the student folk they're
always a collection of popular culture
things which which are which they like a
lot and so it has data on many kinds of
popular culture things there's the the
distribution of weights and heights of
different of a certain kind of Pokemon
if that's what you're interested in or
for example here it has a lot of data on
on kind of popular culture so so here
for instance some is strange okay I
thought it was going to give me a word
cloud for this popular song maybe I
maybe I have the name of the song wrong
i'm not i'm not a big expert on these
kinds of things um but it should give us
a nice some uh huh so that's figuring
out what to do oh there we go okay so
okay yeah it's not not not them okay not
the most exciting sort of words there so
so okay the the this this whole
wolframalpha effort which wolf Malfoy
came out a little bit more than five
years ago now it's something that's been
there's both the consumer-facing version
of wolfram alpha which I'm showing you
here which is operating on public
data there's a pro version which
operates on data that people upload
small amounts of data that people upload
there are custom versions that we've
been building for a whole variety of
organizations that make use of internal
corporate data using the same technology
stack this has all been a it's also a
wolf's mouth has also been used in lots
of other places for example in various
intelligent assistants like Siri and so
on and it's it's been a big effort
acquiring a great deal of data getting
that data and making it computable in a
sense the sort of first step with data
is to get it so that it's in digital
form and you can in principle get blobs
of data the next step is to set the data
up so that if there's a question that
can in principle be answered on the
basis of that data it's actually
possible to automatically get the
question answered and that's a kind of
much higher standard for for the data
and that's a lot of the effort that goes
into alpha alpha is taking data from
sort of digital form to computable form
injecting kind of the expert knowledge
and the methods of models and
calculations that are needed around the
data to actually be able to ask
questions answer questions on the basis
of the data well we developed all the
stuff for from alpha we've got thousands
of different domains of data many many
terabytes of curated data and so on the
exciting thing that we've been able to
do now is to leverage all that effort in
building this data into the Wolfram
language so it's some let me let me kind
of kind of show you a little bit about
the Wolfram language kind of the idea is
as I say to have a language where as
much knowledge as possible is built
right into the language so let's let's
try and get started with some things
here so you know you can interact with
the language you type in a question you
get back an answer you know if we if we
type in you know let's say we type
something like this in we we get a plot
or we could type in something some
something slightly a little bit more
elaborate we'd get my all-time favorite
science picture or we could type in
something like this and now we would
start getting a little user interface
built we have this manipulate that is
now set up to to provide a user
interface that allows us to compute
things well the idea of the Wolfram
language is to be very general to be
able to compute with any kind of data
we're interested in and so for example
if we want to we can compute with let's
say networks I could pull in my kind of
facebook graph it's pretty boring this
is a really good approximation to my
facebook graph a random random graph
with some number of nodes we can we can
go ahead and take this graph and now we
can just let's just pick up this graph
here and we can just go ahead and do
computations on that graph so for
example here I worked out communities
within that graph and so on or i could
take come as well as dealing with
networks i could deal for example with
images let's see what happens if i do
this let's see um okay let's try it
again okay lousy picture but that's okay
so so I could take that image and I
could just go ahead I mean let me pick
that image up here and just go ahead and
put that in here and we can compute with
this image we can then you know break it
up into little pieces we could for
example them let's try let's try doing
this here let's try and we could maybe
assemble that image again and we now
we've got it assembled little pieces
let's try and run edge detection on that
image we get a result and so on so again
sort of a different type of data that
the Wolfram language can deal with is
image data and we have sort of built
into the Wolfram language kind of the
actually sort of the world's most
complete at this point so a collection
of kind of algorithms and meta
algorithms for for image processing all
sort of direct
built in a coherent way into the
language so so these are things are
dealing with kind of abstract data the
one of the big points of the Wolfram
language is it also knows about real
things in the world so we can ask it you
know sunrise today or something like
this so we could say let's ask it about
planets and what i'm doing here is i'm
typing something in that's making use of
the wolfram alpha natural language
understanding stack so i can just type
in these little control equals things i
can just type standard natural language
and it will be interpreted in into
precise Wolfram language form so here i
can say let's say list of entities okay
there are a bunch of planets i could say
for example give me for the the entity
value associated with each of those
entities of an image so here I'll get
images of planets and maybe I can go and
do some simple image image thing with
these let's say I just do an image
collage maybe I could just you know I
could for example edge detect that and
so on and I can go and so I can ask ask
the system about lots of kinds of things
so let's say I type in you know g8 or
something he'll probably interpret that
hopefully as a group of countries okay
so let's say I say let's um let's for
example ask it to show me the the flag
entity for each of those countries okay
i have those flags i could go ahead and
do well I can do whatever I wants here I
could you know I could do again I could
do edge detection on those flags if I
wanted to all those kinds of things or
for example I could say let's say I do I
want to know the capital cities of those
countries okay there they are now notice
that these things that I'm dealing with
here these are entities so the Wolfram
language is a symbolic language so
everything is represented in this very
uniform way is kind of a symbolic
expression some things that are
represented as symbolic expressions of
things like networks or images other
kinds of things that are represented as
symbolic expressions are things in the
world like cities or planets of those
types of things well so I could then
take
one of those one of those cities and I
could go ahead and I could say show me
geographics of a Geo disk five miles
around the center of Washington DC
there's the result and and of course we
have mapping data for the earth and so
on in the system and that we can compute
with and and so on so a little bit more
on the Wolfram language is another thing
we've tried to make the the system as as
automatic as possible so for example a
big thing that we built in was lots of
state-of-the-art machine learning
algorithms and you can just feed in data
and say for example set up a classifier
for this data and then we can take that
classifier that's been built and apply
it to a particular piece of input and we
get that result well let's try something
in a sense it's a kind of form of
curation that we have with machine
learning so let's take some data in
let's let's pull in the plain text from
the front page of the UN website okay
and then let's go ahead and take that
data and let's split it into one string
per line and then let's go ahead and say
and use a kind of a curated classifier
that we've built which classifies human
languages and we can go ahead and say
classify that into which human language
each of those assurances is and so long
as there long enough for it to be able
to tell what's going on it should be
able to tell us what language they are
so this is some so these are kinds of
things that are that are built in to the
into the Wolfram language one of the
another another type of thing also sort
of leverages this kind of concept of
symbolic computation is we can do things
like build reports and for us kind of a
the template for a report it's just
another symbolic expression so we can go
ahead and say you know that the time is
and then we can say let's put an
expression here that says now and then
let's say I don't know that so so we're
building up a report here this report is
just a symbolic expression we go ahead
and say let's generate an actual out
put of this report this is the template
for a report where that so now if we
generate the output it'll say the time
is and then it will fill in for now or
fill in the actual time so so this is
just another another piece of the of the
whole picture of sort of everything as a
symbolic expression well so are the
documents that we're dealing with so are
the templates for reports that we're
producing and so on okay so one of the
one of the sort of the the big ideas
here is to sort of unify everything into
this one knowledge-based language
another big idea is to take that
language and make sure that it can be
sort of deployed everywhere so what I
was showing you here was the language
just running directly on my computer the
you can also use the language in the
cloud so for example I can just go to
the cloud here and my hope yeah and I
could go just purely in a web browser
and I could do the exact same things
that I was doing before you know I can
do my little computations and so on and
I could for example let's say I set up a
plot here I could do any any of the
computations that I was doing before I
can do now directly in the cloud just in
a web browser and so now we're creating
we call the the kind of computable
documents that were producing CDF's with
computable document format documents
this is now a cloud CDF where we're just
operating directly in the cloud but I
can now interact with with with things
if I if I took that and I put it in on
the desktop then you'd see the exact
same thing happening although now it
doesn't have to go back and forth to it
to a server it can operate purely
locally there so it's so that sort of
this complete interface is available in
the cloud you can do some very
interesting kinds of deployments in the
cloud you can also take the same set of
things and deploy them on mobile devices
and sort of the concept of the language
is to support sort of all forms of
computing from the very small to the
very large so you'll see the language
running on giant super campy
videos in a massively parallel form and
you'll also see the language running on
tiny embedded processors that are kind
of the size of one's one's thumb or
something there are so there are many
different places that the language can
be deployed the idea is also to do what
I've shown you is kind of this
interactive session that's a very
convenient way to kind of explore and
discover and create things with the
language but there's also a lot of
deployment that one can do with the
language there are many many forms of
deployment so for example one thing we
can do is let's say we want to build a
little web app lets build a form on the
web so this is going to say create a
form and it's the web so cats are
popular so let's make this say a
something that involves some cat breeds
so what I'm telling it to do if it will
let me sign in oh come now let's try
that one more time the
okay let's see if this works this time
come on think about it no there we go
okay so what this is doing is it's
saying deploy to the cloud a form and
the form is going to have one field
that's called breed and that expects to
be being given a cat breed and then what
it's going to do the actual action that
this little web app is going to do is
it's going to produce a picture of that
cat breed okay so let's try it so now we
have a form here that has this one field
that us for breed and this is what we
call the smart field it's a field that's
making use of our natural language
understanding stack to be able to let
one just enter things in plain natural
language so we can say Siamese here
let's submit that and we duly get a
Siamese cat picture let's make it let's
make this a little bit more complicated
let's say we let's make our form have
two fields let's say one field is the
cat breed one field as an angle and what
we're going to do now so let's try our
Siamese cat again and let's say at 60
degrees and then what should happen is
we should get the same thing a picture
of the cat at 60 degrees okay so so what
we're seeing here is some we're taking
just wolfing language code and we are
creating something that can be deployed
on the web so when we create that form
we can interact with it on the web when
we ask it to do a computation it will go
to our servers do the computation return
the results to the web and you can set
that up in a very general way so for
example here I could also set up an API
that's a cat breed API so now I can go
and I go to the web and this will now be
an API okay I'll need to actually give
it some input here I say breed equals
Siamese in the RESTful API so I'm giving
this on the on the URL line and now I
could have embedded that if i needed a
cat breed picture inside my um my
application I could have embedded that
anywhere in my application and called it
from that application now this this
thing this API is just a symbolic object
like everything else and we can take
that symbolic object and manipulated in
various ways
for example we can say give me embed
code that will give me that will have
code for calling that API from inside
and external Java program i can do it
for lots of different sort of all the
popular computer languages and so on so
what this will do is it will set things
up so that if i put this code in my java
program it will then call out to this
piece of Wolfram language code in the
cloud and undo a computation with it so
it's some and this is something there's
a kind of a complicated technology stack
here because in this case I'm having
this embed code call out to our cloud to
get a computation done you can call out
to our public cloud you can have a
private cloud inside your infrastructure
you can also have a local version of the
Wolfram engine that this exact same
piece of code can be set up to call a
local engine on your machine or
alternatively you can actually have the
Wolfram engine as a library and you can
take it and set it up so that the wolf
mention is actually bound linkedin to
your your program so you can create a
program to distribute that will simply
call the api that is actually part of
your program that makes use of the
Wolfram language so the Wolfram language
is it's a very general thing and we're
trying to make a whole collection of
products that make use of it that sort
of support different kinds of workflows
so the first one that came out a couple
of months ago is our programming cloud
and kind of the concept here is it's all
about some creating code and deploying
it in the cloud on the web and so on and
kind of getting one in the shortest
possible time sort of having the minimum
algorithmic start up so to speak going
from sort of the algorithmic idea
through all the kind of knowledge that
we have in the Wolfram language to
something which is deployed in the cloud
and actually running in the shortest
possible time and the it's and as I say
that the the cloud it can either be our
public cloud or it can be a private kind
of corpora
cloud well another another another
platform that we have which is coming
soon is some well there we go is so we
call the discovery platform this is
something which is kind of a step up
from Mathematica mathematical is very
widely used by Rd folk around the world
the discovery platform is kind of the
the full Wolfram language version of the
kinds of things that people do with
Mathematica the notion is to be able to
get sort of unlimited access to all
sorts of data and knowledge to be able
to to make progress in rd and to kind of
use the methodologies that we've been
able to use for years in doing that well
another another thing that we are doing
is some one of the interesting things
with the Wolfram language is we now have
a language which is sort of simple
enough to write and read that sort of it
can be done by anybody from kind of the
this most sophisticated kind of
professionals down to kids who are
learning their first programming
language and one of the things that's
been interesting is we've been sort of
studying using the Wolfram language as a
first programming language because it's
a language way you don't have to type
very much lots happens and it's easy to
look at code and understand roughly what
it does it's kind of a different model
of learning programming languages that's
more analogous to the way people learn
human languages it's sort of an
immersion language learning methodology
that seems to work where you have a
small set of principles which are sort
of the grammar of the language which you
learn after you've been immersed in
actual code that works and been given
sort of the opportunity to to to explore
code on your own so for example we have
a thing we call programming lab which
will be coming out soon which is a
system aimed at at kids that uses the
Wolfram language to basically explore
programming
kind of from from the very beginning so
that's a kind of that was a sort of an
unexpected application of building sort
of a an extremely high level programming
language is we sort of automated enough
that it becomes accessible to kids and
so on and very engaging and something
where one can sort of teach
computational thinking not just in the
context of computer science but in the
context of any other kind of class
whether it's a geography class or or a
history class or something like that
we've got all sorts of knowledge that in
the system that immediately lets you do
computational thinking in those kinds of
contexts well so in terms of things that
we're building from the Wolfram language
another big one is our data science
platform this is something which is
optimized for kind of the the data
science workflow and sort of the basic
concept is data comes in from somewhere
analysis happens using all of these
things that we have in the Wolfram
language and then reports get generated
at the at the end and this this whole
workflow is some is something that at
this point we can do in a very nice
clean way let me try to show you let's
try and show you this
so I should be able to show you there we
go okay so what this is going to do is
so you can set up new data you can
upload data files you can connect to
external data sources and so on and we
can then we can then go see what I've
got here okay so then this this will be
a typical kind of template the hope that
one might build in the data science
platform let's see what this is ok so
this is a template that has to do with
tracking my personal email inbox and
it's looking at the number of unread
messages that I have and so on in my in
my inbox and now we can go ahead and say
deploy this as an automated report so we
have all kinds of options here but i
think if i go ahead and say create a
report here oops create a report it will
go and go off and try and start creating
a report and i can tell it to go and
usually it would have a schedule to to
generate the report i can say run the
report now and it will go off and i hope
see where do i go to find the report
what happens it here we go okay so
here's so here's the results are running
that report and this is this is so grim
that's my that's my pending email queue
for the past for the past year with a
few good periods look at that um the so
so this is this is kind of an example of
our data science platform and again the
concept is data comes in analytics
happens in the middle I could probably
run a bunch of machine learning and time
series analysis on my on my email queue
and discover some things I might or
might not like to know and then at the
end reports are generated either on a
schedule sent by email alerts are
generated all these kinds of things so
this is kind of a concept of our of our
data science platform that will be will
be coming out shortly and by the way all
these reports are can be our CDF
documents so they can all be interactive
too and you can have dynamic kinds of
things going on within these reports
well okay let me talk a little bit more
technically about what's going on inside
the the data science platform one of the
important elements there is as if we can
get this one of the important elements
is a thing we call a semantic import so
this is making use of our natural
language understanding stack to take
typically typical uses is fairly
structured data but data that is
structured but not yet semantics so here
I'll just go and and read some data off
the web and hopefully I'll be able to
who don't know how big this data is and
what will be happening is a semantic
import oh it's a bad sign the who knows
try it one more time the that's that's
it that's it
you think I should quit the i'll retry
this
alright so so anyway what it should be
doing is taking some lump of data off
the off the sort of raw web and and
going ahead and trying to use our
natural language understanding stack to
yo here we go to read in that data and
to notice that okay they're a bunch of
within that data which is just plain
text they're a bunch of states that it
can recognize as actual entities that
are understood by the Wolfram language
and so on and now okay so they're
fifteen thousand entries there so now we
can go ahead and let's say let's do an
actual computation I had one here that
is now going and making use of some kind
of data data manipulation and analysis
let's see what this does this should be
munging that data and producing
something interesting from it so I think
this is own or what this is is some kind
of income inequality data so we can go
ahead and just be doing this and now
from from that raw data from the web we
were able to turn it into something
meaningful and then able to start doing
analytics on it so this is some it's
kind of the first step in the pipeline
for the data science platform you don't
need to turn your data into something
semantics but you can turn your data
into something semantic this semantic
import was happening all locally if I
gave it some slightly different options
and so on it would be using the whole
natural language understanding stack and
ontology that we have within wolfram
alpha 2 to understand the data that I
was feeding in in fact we have a thing
that's coming soon called the semantic
server which is a system that makes use
of our whole semantic stack as a service
that can be applied inside inside other
programs and so on well one of the
things that we've done here is one of
the questions is okay you've got this
data how should you represent it in
system and you know there's SQL and
there's no SQL and this
rocca cool databases and relational
databases and so on one thing that we've
done is to make use of kind of the
symbolic language ideas of the wolfen
language to come up with something which
is kind of a a modern symbolic melding
of kind of the relational and
hierarchical database ideas so here's an
example this is a simple data set of
planets and their moons and so now we
can go ahead and start time doing things
here and we can see let's say we want
all planets and we want the radius of
all the planets okay there we go that's
easy then we can say let's say we want
some all planets we want their moons we
want the length of the sequence of moons
of the list of moons so that will tell
us how many moons each planet has and
maybe we can go ahead and take that
result and make a pie chart and show
that you know which planet is the is the
winning one in terms of number of moons
or we could do something a little bit
more sophisticated where we're starting
to make use of more kind of more of the
symbolic character of the language we're
saying take planets and their moons and
look at the moon that's maximal by the
key mass we could go ahead and say same
kind of thing we could then apply
another function here that just extracts
the keys and we'll find the the most
massive moon for each planet and so on
well we could go ahead and say let's
take come stakes them a little bit more
complicated let's take all the planets
all their moons and now we're going to
just feed that into something which is
finding the quantity that the radius of
each planet and then making this little
piece of graphics and so now we've got
some little little infographic of the
moons of various planets in order and
their sizes and so on so so the concept
here is we're making use of sort of the
power of symbolic programming that we
have in the Wolfram language to create
this kind of new way of thinking about
databases that can be manipulated
symbolically okay well so within this
data set system the we actually have a
whole hierarchy of different ways to
work with data and as we do throughout
the Wolfram language and throughout our
technology stack we try to automate
things as much as possible so that the
user doesn't have to really think about
what the kind of the mechanics going on
underneath are so sort of at the first
level ones just manipulating data in
memory and just doing computations where
everything is stored in memory there's a
second level ones dealing with files as
a third level ones dealing with existing
databases a fourth level ones dealing
with distributed databases we're
gradually sort of climbing up these
successive levels to be able to
manipulate larger and larger kinds of
data using the exact same language and
code and mechanisms that we have for
much smaller data so you'll be able to
use the data science platform with the
exact same kind of programming for all
these different sizes of data well
there's a whole elaborate framework of
dealing with data that exists that we
built for from alpha that involves not
only sort of the underlying querying of
data in all sorts of ways but also the
ability to use natural language to ask
questions about data and it sort of been
an interesting competition in the
development of often alpha we've got
some underlying querying technology for
our data and databases and so on and
we've got linguistic understanding
technology and every so often one of
them gets ahead of the other so we
sometimes we can understand more queries
than we can actually compute with
sometimes we can compute with more
queries than we can understand but we're
gradually trying to sort of move both of
these things up and we're trying to set
it up so that this kind of natural
language querying mechanism is also
available directly within the world from
language I should say that the the
Wolfram language has plenty of ability
to deal with natural language right now
so for example one typical thing is we
have these things we call interpreters
and this is again using the natural
language understanding stack that we
have we say interpret as a city the
string NYC this is how these smart
fields that I was shown before in our
forms work we could say interpret as a
semantic number TW o space thirds and it
will go ahead and interpret this a hope
it should be instantaneous what's it
doing
they're um scary okay try it again the
who knows the um yeah there are there
are lots and lots of different tongue
domains of let's see we've got some we
could we could say we could ask it what
different types of interpreters do you
know about and there's hundreds of
different kinds of interpreters I'm so
for example we could say let's let's
give it let's say we're expecting a
disease and the actual string we're
given its heart attack it will then
canonicalize that to some standard thing
that's represented I think this is an
icd-9 code here so we can now so this is
a way of building our this is this is
how we start to build natural language
capabilities into the system and in fact
we have a much more sophisticated
version of this that's um that's coming
soon where one can define one's own
grammars and then make use of as
elements of those grammars make use of
things that are built in to the the
natural language understanding stack
that we already have so for example this
would deploy a very simple grammar that
is for setting an alarm clock so it has
a very simple piece of linguistics for
setting the alarm clock and it has a
grammar token here that says expect a
semantic time that will be we'll make
use of the whole standard natural
language understanding stack so this is
a way that I think people will end up
building lots of kinds of natural
language querying methods for for
databases lots of ways to control
devices using natural language and so on
making use of our existing natural
language understanding stack so for
instance let's see if I can pick one up
here so this should be this is this is a
fairly elaborate example this is using
the g database connecting to a Google
bigquery database and then using a
slightly more elaborate drama here and
then just pulling in data and so now it
has says this database is a database of
new
use and so this has a map of ceasefire
violations in 2014 apparently based on
based on that based on that natural
language data set and this is all
happening weathers the actual query here
is the natural language query that the
the grammar for that natural language
query is defined here leveraging the
natural language understanding stack
then that grammar that query is turned
into something computable which is going
off and and calling this the APA the
this doing these queries in the back end
to then eventually generate this some
geo map there well so this is this is
one of one of the things we're doing one
thing that's so that's interesting when
you let's say you generate a report
somehow use natural language use the
wolfman language use the data science
platform you you generate a report and
you've got that report generator a board
you generate graphics you embed that
graphic somewhere on the web something
like this the question is where did that
graphic come from usually when you see a
graphic in some research report or some
such other thing it's just like okay
there's a picture that's nice maybe you
can read some text around it maybe you
can figure out from that text where the
graphic comes from how it was generated
our idea is that whenever you have
something like a graphic generated from
our technology stack there'll be what we
call a compute back link and so
underneath a little thing that says
source you click that and you'll be able
to see depends on how the author set it
up exactly how much you can see but
you'll you'll in principle be able to
see the Wolfram language notebook as we
call them that generated that graphic so
you can start going back and saying okay
here's a picture now what generated this
well what generated this was this piece
of code here that piece of code is
making use of that of data here that
data is again accessible directly
through the technology stack so kind of
the notion is that you can you can when
you
that you don't just have dead pictures
in your reports and so on you instead
have things where you can go back and
see how they were computed and you can
make use of the underlying data and so
on I think in time this is going to be
what people expect they they want
something where they can actually build
on the material that's in the report I
should say that if the report is done
with CDF for example the actual report
itself can be interactive and you can
again use this computer ISM to go and
see where all that code came from and so
on I think in in research sort of the
idea is you know is it a data backed
publication or is it just some dead
publication that doesn't have sort of
data backing it up well so when you have
this data where do you store it well you
can store it in our cloud and you one of
the things we'll be doing is building a
sort of global data repository using our
cloud that can make lumps of data
available sort of published data
globally do very interesting things with
data in our technology stack in our
cloud for example we can use our whole
semantic import mechanism to be able to
make that data semantic to be able to
understand the meaning of the data to
make the data computable we can sort of
it's absolutely routine for us to be
doing visualizations and analysis and so
on on that data that's all stuff that
for us is kind of for free once we once
we have a data repository with with data
in it so one of the things i should
mention is when we think about making
data semantic we have something that we
call wdf that is something that more
will be emerging about in the next year
or so the idea of wdf if we could only
get to actual place okay there's no yard
even has a tag on it does it take data
and make it meaningful the concept is to
be able to make use of our ontology and
semantic structures and so on to take
whatever data you have
represented in a symbolic semantic way
and in a sensory you can think about
this as taking everything we built for 4
from alpha and its ontology and kind of
opening that up so that everybody can
hang things off the ontology that we've
built full of malva and the great thing
about the wolf's mouth for ontology is
we actually know it works because we
have an actual big system that's running
off all of this ontology it's not some
theoretical ontology that we made up
it's something that has actually been
built based on real data and a real
working system so and it's also it's not
a static ontology it's an ontology that
sort of has full sort of computability
and it maintains dynamic algorithmic
relationships and so on so that this is
a wdf is kind of the the representation
that we'll be using for our data
repository it's also the representation
that I data science platform works with
um another thing perhaps to mention is
that tongue so so we make use a lot of
you you IDs in dealing with with data
and dealing with objects in our cloud
and so on you you IDs are important
because you generate a uuid and you can
be guaranteed that it's going to be
unique wherever you generate it from so
if you have private clouds and private
some data data repositories for example
you can be representing entities in
those data repositories with you you IDs
and you're guaranteed that those those
entities will not collide with each
other and generically data sets that
will be dealing with will just be
represented by you you IDs but some of
the data sets will be data sets that we
want to curate and give names to and so
on and one of the projects that we have
now is curating named data sets so what
we have been doing in the past is taking
data and making the data sort of every
individual piece of the data computable
sort of the idea now is to take whole
data sets that are sort of named things
that people know about and and to set
those up as kind of entities
on their own and and be able to make use
of them and hopefully I think many
people here we've worked with data set
some that that you guys work with I
think there will be many data sets that
it makes sense to put in sort of raw
form as curated named data sets into our
infrastructure one of the things that
term ok so we're intending to do a lot
of curation of data sets as entities so
to speak another thing that we are
curating is api's there are lots of API
is in the world and we're interested in
setting things up so that it becomes
easy for people to to query api's let me
see if I can do this here um let's try
this so when we come so the notion is
that we have a variety of api's here are
a few AP is that we're dealing with here
there are different kinds of services
and the idea is that we can connect to
one of these services here we're
connecting to open library ok we just
opened a connection to open library now
we can do a search in open library and
what we're doing here is we're having a
fairly raw ok so i just searched for
myself as an author in open library and
it came up with a bunch of books there
maybe i can do a search for a particular
book and try and pull up a cover of a
particular book i wonder where i wonder
where that where that particular cover
comes from ok we can't tell the butt but
the notion here is that we are we're
curating AP is so that within our system
you can get easy access to to a whole
variety of different AP is in the past
we've we've curated data formats for
example so that probably 500 different
data formats that we can import and
export from within the Wolfram language
we're now doing the same kind of thin
with with AP eyes and kind of our
approach is to go on to pause we're
having what we call connected services
which
ap is where it's a question of having
the ability to connect and but we're not
kind of dealing with all of the
authentication issues with that API you
may need to have sort of separate
authentication with that API I mean
we're supporting OAuth and things within
the Wolfen language but you may need to
have sort of a separate key that you
arranged with with whatever the vendor
of the API is so that's the first step
is kind of connected services the second
step is what we call integrated services
where we are dealing with the
interaction with the API vendor and
where the notion is that we're using our
cloud infrastructure and the billing
mechanisms and so on and our cloud
infrastructure to let people just use
those api's as integrated services
within our language with with separate
sort of arrangements on the back end
with with the vendors of those api's I
think that in both of these models it's
a pretty interesting way for lots of
kinds of organizations to expose their
their data because we have this whole
kind of infrastructure for for taking
data and letting people compute with it
whether it's directly within the Wolfram
language or in apps that people build on
the basis of lawton language and so on
okay so one of the things that sort of
has opened up a lot for us in this area
is the fact that we now have a whole
micro payment mechanism through our
cloud infrastructure that makes it
possible for us to interface with with
with other kinds of api's and so on okay
final thing I want to talk about is
another kind of source of data which is
the Internet of Things and connected
devices so we're keen to make use of the
Wolfram language instead of a high-level
language for the Internet of Things and
it's very important for that purpose
that the wolfen language has sort of
built-in data semantics as well as a lot
of existing built-in data so when we
deal with them when we deal with
connected devices one mechanism that we
have for dealing with them is absolutely
directly within the Wolfram language
there's a framework for just actually
connecting to a device so you can say
you know device read time series and you
can connect to a device and you can
start reading a time series of data from
that device that's a device that you
actually plug in with a wire to your
computer and so so there's a whole
mechanism for dealing with that and for
handling for example the time series of
data that come from such devices the
other thing that happens in the modern
world is that one has some devices that
are somehow connected to computers
through some wireless connection or
through the web or something like that
one of the things that we did because
we're into curating things we decided I
was curious just what are the various
connected devices that are out there in
the world and so I thought let's just
curate all the connected devices that
are out there in the world so far there
are 3682 in our list and this is a big
long collection of all sorts of
different kinds of connected devices
that measure all sorts of different
kinds of things I'm if we say what kinds
of measured quantities to these measure
you know some are measuring radiation
dose some of measuring illuminance you
know body mass index and so on each a
different set of devices and of course
all this data is we've made computable
and it's in more from alpha and so on
well for any one of these devices
there's what one might call sort of the
first mile problem how does you how do
you go from the device the scale that's
sitting on the floor or something to the
cloud okay and there's a whole sort of
messy area that's going on right now of
how you sort of solve that first mile
problem but let's assume that that
problem has been solved then our goal is
to take whatever can be fed into the
cloud and be able to build a pipeline
for doing analytics and making the data
that's coming from that some from that
connected device as useful as possible
whether it's producing a dashboard or
making an API or synthesizing
measurements across lots of devices and
so on so we're making sort of a general
device on
it's platform that's primarily intended
for device manufacturers so that they
can they can just concentrate on
building their device and then it's up
to us to handle the whole cloud
analytics infrastructure and so on
aspects of this well there's an
important element that we're building to
support that kind of activity
something's not out yet but it's
something we call our data drop and the
the concept of our data drop is it's a
universal data accumulator for as it
says devices sensors programs humans and
more and so the notion of the data drop
is you accumulate data from anywhere
it's got a Web API you can send an email
you can embed code in Java that pushes
things to the data drop you can tweak to
it you can get data in from an Arduino
and do all kinds of different things but
the notion is you're somehow you're
getting data into the data drop so I can
show you a little bit about how that
works so let's let's go and that's so
obviously one way you can get data into
the data drop let's kill the soft we
don't need that anymore one way you can
get data into the data drop of course is
using the Wolfen language so we can say
create a bin here this is creating a
data been great let's connect here oh
this will connect
that is a very bad sign the let me see
whether anything is alive here you think
so that says that's the tallies
universal answer for what to do when
these belong that's uh well let's try it
again so that must be the key to our R&D
effort um see if this works huh did work
okay okay so what we did here is we
created a data bin okay and it has a
certain ID and it has various other
characteristics and now we can go and
take take that bin and we can say okay
let's you know add and that's the the
data that we're going to add to the data
bin is just there's this variable now
that just gives us the current time so
we go ahead and say you know we can add
that to the data bin again we could you
know write a loop that just says do you
know do that three times or something
you know just go ahead and and just keep
adding it every time you'll see it it's
adding entries to this data bin and now
we can go ahead and say if we want to we
can say okay what values are there in
the data been and there will see the
things that we pushed into this data
been and now we can go ahead and say we
can do all kinds of computations with
this I mean if we wanted to I don't know
whether I want to tempt fate here i can
probably try them let me see if I can do
this let's try just dumb let us try
taking the state of in or is it that's
the name of the data band oops and let
me just try no I wonder that little line
sent with post box looks a little weird
but let's just try sending in I'm
sending some I sure you ready to send
this message why wouldn't I be ready to
send this message maybe I should take
off those
that's important but okay the oh that
was actually what I had back there was
some those were some that was that was
male from the data science platform
telling me that the report that I told
it to generate ages ago was actually
generated when I told it to generate it
but now what I should have here
hopefully is no maybe not um I should
have been able to add that data to the
data Bennett's if that worked no it
didn't had but the male has gone astray
somewhere but the idea anyway if I'd
actually typed the right things in is
that you can you can feed stuff to the
data bin to the data drop in lots of
easy ways so here's an example this is a
data bin that was created this is a data
bin that's based on a sensor that's
sitting in a refrigerator in a break
room at our company okay and the sensor
is measuring temperature and enlight and
so I think if we can go ahead and it's
been just collecting data it's got 2,300
data points and we can go ahead and say
let's go let's go get the data
associated with this data bin and let's
see whether we can see whether it
connects to this thing and so on so this
is this is going to our cloud and
reading I hope should be instantaneous
this is a very strange well it did
something okay so now we can say for
example let's make a let's take that
data it's got two events series here and
so this is for example the temperature
event series for the refrigerator and I
I guess that's a return the door of the
refrigerator was open there's a
temperature spike and so on we could go
ahead and and say let's take the let's
make a histogram of the temperatures of
the refrigerator over this over this
period of time and we should see a
result there or we could we could do all
kinds of things from this but what's
interesting here is this was this is
just some some little sensor and all it
knows is a web address and it's just
pushing data to that web address and
then within our stack we're able to
access that data and by the way if
type this data bin ID into wolfram alpha
we will soon be able to also generate a
report directly with them or falfa and
downstream within all the intelligent
assistance that are based on wolf mouth
or and so on so that you can just push
data into our data drop and then you can
go ask Siri or whatever else something
about that data and it will be able to
give you a report on that data well lots
of it'll be for a low frequency data it
will be free for people to just push
data into our data drop you also be able
to arrange to to get high frequency data
pushed into the into the data droppin to
get private clouds and so on that that
can store versions of our day to drop
all kinds of elaborate things like that
um and I think come one of the things to
realize about data that's going from
connected devices is we're interested in
having processing be able to happen with
our language in lots of different places
so in this case the data drop is taking
data from a potentially quite dumb
device pushing it into our cloud and
then we're doing computations on the
data in the cloud another possibility is
that the device itself is smart enough
to be able to run our language and I
mentioned that we are developing
versions of the language for various
embedded processors there will be a
variety of versions of that already
since the end of last year our language
has been bundled on the Raspberry Pi
little tiny $25 Linux machine and that's
a place where one can sort of take the
processing and put it inside the device
so once one's having sort of wolfing
language code that can run doing sort of
pre-processing on data taking an image
and doing first pre-processing on it
right within the device or you can make
the decision to move the data to the
cloud and do the processing there and it
becomes a purely sort of tactical
decision whether you have the processing
done on the device or in the cloud well
lots of applications of all this kind of
thing there's a whole sort of personal
analytics adventure some of you may know
I've been
I've been a data enthusiast for a long
time so I've collected huge amounts of
data on my on myself for 25 years or so
that's my trace of email as a function
of time and lots lots and lots of data
but this is something that will become
easier and easier for people to do and
feed it from connected devices through
our data drop into the cloud and
actually get computations done we've
also some of you may know we've we've
worked a lot on things like Facebook
data this is data that we got based on
the personal analytics that we provide
within Wolfram Alpha you can you can
connect wolf alpha to your maybe not you
can connect to of Malfi to to Facebook
and you can have it do an analysis of
the data that Facebook has about you
based on the Facebook API and from a
large number of people doing that
analysis and a fair number of people
checking the box to become data donors
for us and for another set of people
allowing us to use anonymized data from
them we were able to do this very large
study of of kind of the the world
according to to Facebook so to speak and
that's sort of a typical type of thing
that's again possible through kind of
the the whole pipeline of data analytics
that we've been building so i might
mention we're talking about some devices
and so on there's a question of when you
when you have different kinds of devices
how many different kinds of things could
you in principle measure well this is
something that we actually know because
we've curated this form alpha there are
there about 10,000 kinds of things that
people measure that I that you find in
the literature whether it's you know
dynamic viscosity or whether it's one
that really confused me was moles per
acre which is not a which is actually
the number of
it's a thing for in agriculture where it
actually involves actual moles aerating
the soil and it's a certain number per
acre but anyway so that's one of the ten
thousand different kinds of things that
people measure so one question is to to
sort of curate all those different kinds
of measurement and the other question is
what what kinds of devices do you need
to do all those kinds of measurements
and one of the things that we've
realized from curating these different
kinds of measurements and so on is that
there's actually a whole sort of global
measurement graph that says okay so for
example you can say you know this is
just a this is that she doesn't not yet
available in Wolfram Alpha but will be
soon you know devices that measure
dynamic viscosity and it knows the
various different kinds of devices that
measure dynamic viscosity and it knows
the ranges of measurements and so on and
so on and so on so one question is if
you're going to set up if you're going
to try and measure 10,000 different
kinds of things do you need 10,000
different kinds of sensors to do that
and the answer is absolutely not you
there's a certain what you can do is
take all those different kinds of
measurements and you can say what are
the fundamental primitives that you can
build up those measurements from so for
example there are some broad spectrum
sensors like a camera is a good sort of
broad spectrum sensor because with a
camera when you get data from a camera
you can process that data to figure out
all kinds of things like you can have a
camera just look at you and it can see
that you know your your skin is getting
you know redder and less red as as you
know for every heartbeat and so just by
taking an image and processing that
image you can deduce heart rate so
similarly there are many different kinds
of things that you can deduce of those
10,000 different kinds of things you can
measure you can start building up this
graph of from what can you deduce what
and so we've been interested in kind of
thinking about what would it take to
make sort of a universal sensor platform
that has a small number of kind of broad
spectrum sensors it might be a mass
spectrometer it might be some chemical
sensor it might be something that some
hyperspectral imaging sensor might be a
bunch of different things that are sort
of broad spectrum sensors but a small
number of them maybe a dozen less
but from those sensors be able to just
use science effectively to build up an
actual way to measure each of those
10,000 different possible things that
can be measured and so so we've been
interested in figuring this out and I
don't yet have a version of this
Universal sensor platform but it's sort
of a direction that we've been we've
been going in and sort of our notion is
to build kind of the data operating
system that goes above this Universal
sensor platform so underneath Universal
sends a platform its measuring stuff but
what you say is I want to measure
quantity X I want to measure wind speed
and somehow underneath the some
measurements will be made by this
Universal sensor platform and then our
sort of data operating system layer
we'll figure out the actual thing that
you want to compute so okay so there's
kind of a this is this is sort of a
direction that we're going for kind of
under the with the Internet of Things
instead of having you know 5,000
different kinds of devices have a
universal sensor platform that purely
and software can be made to measure
different different types of things
there's sort of a lot of different kinds
of data that one can deal with I just
mentioned okay one to two last examples
so i suppose a sort of meta theme of
this conference is there's lots of very
fascinating data out there in the world
there's much more many more things in
the world that you can measure and get
data about then you might possibly
imagine i'll just mention to two areas
that we're going into which are sort of
examples of a of a new new types of
curation and new types of data data work
that we're dealing with so one type of
data work has to do with machines and
devices and systems so for example we
have already built in I hope see if this
comes back data about all sorts of
physical system so there's about a
harmonic oscillator and we know all
kinds of
a buret wave functions for harmonic
oscillators and who knows what else but
one of the things we want to do is there
are many different kinds of machines in
the world and we actually have a product
called system modeler which is aimed at
the systems engineering market where
people represent all sorts of elaborate
and complicated machines using a
language called modelica which is sort
of a standard language for representing
engineering systems and the idea is that
you can you can represent all those
different kinds of machines whether it's
a machine that is some sort of abstract
kind of machine that you made up or
whether it's a machine that some
particular vendor sells all of these
things can be represented symbolically
in this modelica language we can take a
representation of a machine so there's a
particular machine and now what we're
doing here is simulating the so this
machine it's a rectifier we're now
simulating that rectifier and now we can
go ahead and take the results of that
this is now this is being done right now
by linking our system model a product
into the Wolfram language but what we
are what we are aiming towards is really
integrating all of this capability for
dealing with machines and systems
directly into the orphan language so the
notion there is that we are a sort of a
you know we've curated many kinds of
things we've curated you know cities in
the world we've curated kinds of
chemicals we've curated lyrics of songs
and things we've curated kinds of
connected devices yet another kind of
thing to curate is machines and their
operation but one thing that's
interesting about that curation is it's
very algorithmic curation in the sense
the thing you're curating is the
algorithm that describes the operation
of the machine and so the idea is to do
that for all common kinds of machines
all kinds of things that you can buy
from different vendors and so on and
then to be able to take those curated
representations of machines and be able
to to compute with them directly in the
Wolfram language that's kind of another
type of curation final type of curation
that we've been interested in
is kind of a lot of what we've what
we've been interested for a long time in
math that's why we have a product called
Mathematica for example the one of the
things that's true and math is there's
been a lot of work done in math over the
last many centuries about a hundred
million pages have been written in the
literature of mathematics and they
contain about five million theorems and
so one of the things that we think is
worth doing is just curate all the
published theorems and mathematics why
is that interesting it's interesting
because if you describe kind of a pure
mathematical construct one of the things
that is of great interest is to say well
what theorems that people wrote down
over the past three centuries apply to
this mathematical construct that I'm
thinking about today so we've had a
project actually this is a project that
was it's unfortunately unlike many of
the things that we curate that have
terrific sort of commercial application
curating all the theorems of mathematics
is really a philanthropic effort and
we'd been we have some support from the
sloan Foundation for example for doing a
sort of corner of the curation of of the
of the theorems of mathematics we've
worked particularly on one's about
continued fractions and we've curated
some fraction of all the known theorems
about about those it's sort of
interesting to see what does a what does
it look like underneath what we need is
some kind of representation of just like
we have representations in our language
for networks or representations for
cities representations for other kinds
of things we also need representations
for all of the concepts of pure
mathematics we have many of the concepts
of mathematics that have been applied in
in serious ways we already have from
Mathematica within the Wolfram language
but we need to go on and and sort of
have a representation for all the
different kinds of of concepts that have
come up in instead of those hundred
million pages of literature appeal
mathematics so this is a
a challenge for the future and we've
just been sort of trying to mobilize the
world mathematics community to help with
this challenge and I think it's going to
I think it's going to go fairly well the
within our language to date we have
about 5000 different kinds of different
functions different constructs pure
mathematics is actually a big chunk of
additional additional sets of constructs
probably many hundreds possibly a
thousand more concepts that have to be
added to the language but it's something
that we're working towards so it's some
and one of the things that we're doing
whether it's stealing with machines or
mathematical theorems one of the things
we sort of learnt is that one of the you
know from a sort of our understanding of
data and our understanding of knowledge
and knowledge based systems and so on
we've sort of developed a design
methodology which allows us to take each
successive area and an attack it and
sort of bring it into our kind of
computable knowledge kind of framework
and so I think this is some or this is
this is something that we've been doing
for for many years and every every few
years we get even more ambitious about
the kinds of kinds of areas to which we
can apply this sort of methodology so um
it's so that's that's some so so you
know if you'd asked me a few years ago
this sort of computational knowledge
idea to what can be applied I would have
described you some some set of things as
we understand more about what's possible
and as we build out sort of a bigger
technology stack the set of things that
we can apply this kind of computational
knowledge methodology to expands and I
hope one of the things that we are we're
keen on is to be able to take data that
people organizations have collected over
the course in many cases of many decades
and be able to provide really the best
possible framework for taking that data
and making it as useful as possible
making it so that one
get as many sort of answers from that
data as it as it supports and sort of
compute with it in the best possible way
and I should stop there and i'm sure i
went over time and I'm sorry so thank
thanks very much